the great pandemic bubble is popping and
you need to pay attention here's exactly
how we got to this situation back in
early of 2020 the pandemic struck the
government ordered people to go sit in
their homes and asset prices were in a
free fall that meant that central banks
and politicians were going to step in
and boy did they step in with
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
that led to one of the greatest and
fastest recoveries in economic history
as we pushed into 2021 we then had a
bigger and bigger asset bubble which
eventually peaked in November of last
year at that point the historic
inflation that we were experiencing had
to be gotten under control and so that's
when the FED started to talk tough and
begin to create tighter Financial
conditions as we have watched over the
last 12 months we have seen stocks real
estate Bitcoin cryptocurrencies and
every other asset fall in line now all
of a sudden we are starting to see more
and more Tech layoffs but as we saw in
the first half of the Year many
companies they did those layoffs we saw
all sorts of margin calls and Contagion
in the crypto industry and people
thought how much worse could it get well
now we are seeing the second wave the
big popping of that pandemic bubble
we've seen companies like Lyft lay off
13 of their staff stripe 14 Twitter 50
and then today we got the big news that
Facebook is going to lay off 11
000 employees 11 000 people is a ton
it's only 13 of the company but I don't
think I've ever heard of 11 000 people
getting laid off from one company all at
the same time if we then ask ourselves
why exactly are we in this situation we
can look to the entrepreneurs and the
founders for details we've seen Jack
Dorsey say hey the company grew too
quickly we hired too many people I'm
sorry we've also seen the founders of
stripe say that they didn't know how
quickly things would recover and then
also they didn't know how quickly things
would fall back in line once the FED
started to create tighter Financial
conditions and then of course the story
isn't just about the difficulty in
planning for entrepreneurs or the
layoffs that we're seeing we also saw
yesterday FTX agree to be acquired by
binance rightfully so there's a lot of
people with questions and concerns the
truth is we don't know what's happened
yet and so once that information comes
out we'll then get a better
understanding what went wrong who knew
what when and exactly what does this
mean for certain parts of the industry
moving forward but ultimately loose
monetary policy and undisciplined fiscal
policy drove us into this situation as
we got higher and higher inflation
investors both retail and institutions
will push out further on the risk curve
in order to try to derive returns that
outpace inflation this is a story as old
as time in hindsight the intervention in
markets by Central bankers and
politicians distorted the free market
capabilities and it led to all sorts of
things being broken this is a bad
situation and so many people have been
asking what exactly am I doing I'm only
able to do three things at the moment
I'm building I'm waiting and I'm
learning I'm trying to to build
companies I'm trying to build a strong
balance sheet and I'm trying to build
new skills and knowledge that can be
used when we get to the other side of
this in terms of waiting I simply don't
want to make mistakes there's a lot of
people that make unforced errors in
times of chaos and uncertainty if you
can mitigate those mistakes then you'll
have a better chance of succeeding on
the other side and lastly I'm learning
there's all sorts of different events
that are transpiring and many different
economic developments that are playing
out across the globe I'm paying
attention I'm trying to understand
what's happening because my guess is
this won't be the last Market downturn
that I'll experience in my career and
it's unlikely to be the last Market
downturn you experience in your career
and so the more that I can learn today
the better prepared I'll be next time
building waiting and learning those are
three things that every single person
can spend their time doing right now
this sucks there's people being laid off
there's people losing lots of money and
times are tough remember do everything
you possibly can to be happy spend your
time with friends and family try to do
the things that you enjoy doing yes this
too shall pass it doesn't seem that way
right now but ultimately that's what I
keep telling myself I think it's what
you should keep telling yourself